my name is david patrick columbia where
was I born I was born here in New York
City actually I just came down the
street on which my family lived when I
was born which was on East 25th street
they lived in a tenement building my
father was a chauffeur my mother I don't
think work but I think she was the super
of the building that they lived in so
they could pay the rent they lived there
until I think I they lived there long
before I was born they lived there for
about 10 years before I was born and
then in the first year of my life they
moved to Massachusetts I'm not quite
sure how it shaped me but all of that
really resonates with me every single
time i go down east 25th street and past
the building in which they lived when I
was born I came back to New York when I
was a a 21 to 22 years old I'd flunked
out of college in my junior year and I
came directly to New York I had won a
playwriting contest in college and and
the prize was one hundred dollars and in
1962 you could come to New York with a
hundred dollars in start your life well
I when I was a child I always wanted to
live in New York and I always wanted to
live in Hollywood my father was in New
Yorker and he got the tabloids every day
when I was growing up in Massachusetts
and the tabloid some of the New York
Daily News in the New York Daily Mirror
and he all they were full of columns
like Walter Winchell I was started
reading Walter Winchell when I was six
years old and so I always had a dream of
living in the city I was fascinated with
Hollywood because I was fascinated with
movie stars and movies and things like
that I was always fascinated with show
business I actually at a very early age
when I was in my 20s made an attempt to
do that but I actually was when I
stopped playing with toys which was
about 11 11 or 12 I started to write
down the things that were going on in my
mind when i played with toys so i really
started becoming a writer than i did not
imagine myself as being a writer when i
grew up because
I was always aware of the fact that I
didn't know very much and I always felt
that writers at least those that i read
were extremely knowledgeable and
sophisticated well I became when I was
in my late 30s I had a business and it
was starting to become very successful
and I used I always wrote I always kept
journals from the time I was in my 20s
with the intention of teaching myself to
write honestly and so but I also had a
business to I had actually had done
several things and at this particular
time in my 30s I had a business and I
was becoming very successful and i would
spend more and more of my time writing
my journals with this very successful
business and i realized that if I made a
lot of money which I was on the brink of
doing I would probably never be a writer
so I sold my business and I moved to
California with the intention of
becoming a writer and for quite a long
time for about seven or eight years
after that I really did struggle and
really didn't succeed at all and barely
made any income whatsoever and then I
wrote a book for a movie star named
Debbie Reynolds I wrote her
autobiography which actually got my got
me notice in the publishing world and I
was brought to New York to write a book
for somebody else and I had a feeling
because I knew the man and I had seen
the first book that he did he was an
entertainer I had a feeling that it
might not work out between me and him
even though I liked him socially I told
myself I had to drive here I took the
job because I was broke and I simply
needed money and this was the only thing
in front of me so I decided that I was
very depressed about the whole prospect
because I thought if it didn't work out
I wouldn't have the money to go back to
Los Angeles and I liked living in Los
Angeles so I said to myself just to make
myself feel better if you're going to be
stuck in New York and you want to earn a
living as a writer if you could earn a
living as a writer any way you wanted
what would you like to do and the
thought that came into my head was I
would like to write a social column and
I was always aware of social columns
from the time I was very young from
those tabloids that my father used to
get every day and I was always
fascinated by it and I didn't know how I
could make that
happen because i'm not really a
networker I don't have a networking
personality even though I'm very
outgoing and but serendipitously it came
to pass i met somebody who had a
magazine and I we had somebody mutual in
common and I asked it she asked me if
I'd write an article about this person
and I did and that started my career and
then a year later she asked me if I
wanted to write a column and that's how
it happened